foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar on AI
microscopy Symposium 8th Edition my name
is one young toi I'm the product manager
product owner for avia's AI image
analysis software by Leica Microsystems
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Leica Microsystems to learn more
visit
www.lica Dash microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
that you see on your screen and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers our
first speaker is Dr Helen Spears
biomedical research lead of the
universe and CGI Imaging scientist
fellow
based at the Francis Crick Institute in
London Dr Spears works with many
research teams around the world to
develop novel citizen science projects
tackling a large range of biomedical
research questions
Dr Spears also studies the phenomenon of
Citizen science and is currently
examining multiple aspects of volunteer
experience across this universe prior to
her current position
Dr Spears completed a PhD degree in
developmental epigenetics at King's
College London and works as a medical
writer for two years and obtained the
degree in Biochemistry from the
University of Oxford
our second speaker is Dr Martin's
prisner postdoctoral researcher from
AstraZeneca in Gothenburg Sweden he has
PhD Dr prisoner was working on
strategies for improving microscopy
frame rates using machine learning
techniques and he developed fluorescent
copper probes for the detection of
copper in cells he's a chemist by
training with a degree from Vienna
University of Technology and obtained
another Masters in neurotechnology from
Imperial College London
his research interest is in applying AI
solutions to Scientific problems to
improve measurement techniques and
automate the analysis of data
Dr Spears you may now begin your
presentation
thank you
so thank you for that kind introduction
and many thanks for the invitation to
present today and thank you all in our
audience for taking the time out of your
schedules to join us
um so as you'll have heard my name's Dr
Helen Spears and I'm a transitberg
Imaging scientist
and today I would like to tell you a
little bit about how we've been applying
citizen science for the segmentation of
electron microscopy data and just to
apologize I have a streaming cold so if
I need to go on mute to sneeze or cough
I'll do so
um so in terms of what I'd like to cover
in today's presentation firstly I'd like
to give you all a brief introduction to
Citizen science because I'm not assuming
that any of you will have heard of
Citizen science previously I'll then
provide an introduction to the world's
largest platform for online citizen
Sciences Universe platform I'll then go
on to describe how we're using this
universe platform at the Francis Crick
Institute and then if there's time at
the end of my presentation I'll give a
very brief introduction to how you can
build and launch your own citizen
science project
so firstly what is citizen science so
citizen science can be broadly defined
as involving the public in research and
there are a number of related terms to
Citizen science such as participatory
research community-based research and
other terms and these terms have their
own specific histories and communities
and practice
but they all relate to Citizen science
um together these practices
encompasses a huge range of different
citizen science projects and the logos
here just show a very small fraction of
the total projects out there there are
hundreds of Citizen science projects out
there
so despite their variety citizen science
projects frequently have similar
motivations at their core so Central to
most citizen science projects is the aim
to enable the generation of new
knowledge that would not be possible or
easy to generate otherwise other common
motivations behind citizen science
projects include improving engagement
with science and also democratizing
science through improving access to the
means of knowledge production and also
allowing members of the public to
contribute to asking different sorts of
research questions
um so via What mechanisms do citizen
science projects generate new knowledge
so just to introduce you to some of the
different citizen science projects that
are out there
um some projects use volunteers
familiarity with their local environment
to gather new data so one well-known
project in this context is eBird and
common sense so eBird asks birders to
share bird sightings for an app and
Common Sense allows members of the
public to contribute to air quality
readings to Advanced research
um there are also projects that ask
members of the public to donate idle
computer time and uh boink is one very
well-known volunteer Computing platform
in this context and boink has played
host to a huge variety of different
citizen science projects including seti
at home which some of you may have heard
of it's a very famous project launched
in the 1990s to allow members of the
public to donate their Idol computer
processing time to analyze radio signals
and search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and some of you may have
heard of Rosetta at home which was a
project
uh looking uh to advance understanding
of protein structure
there are also projects which ask
volunteers to share personal qualitative
and quantitative data for further
analysis with well-known examples
including patients like me which is an
online platform for quantitative
personal research where patients with
illnesses can share self-reported
outcomes connect with other communities
and learn from pre-existing data and
more topically more recently there's
also the Zoe Zoe covered symptom study
which was a mobile app developed in
collaboration between King's College
London and guys and Thomas
to collect information in conjunction
with covert symptoms
they're also make movements in which
members of the public connect with other
communities to perform wet lab
experiments to to work with equipment
and to learn protocols and develop
skills
and there are also projects that involve
the analysis of data so well-known
example includes folder which was an
online puzzle game about protein folding
which members of the public
worked to look at protein structure and
then the highest scored proteins with
them further analyzed by researchers and
it is this universe platform that form
that falls into this mode of knowledge
production the analysis of data so the
vast majority of projects on the
Xenoverse platform
involve the analysis of pre-existing
data sets
so this brings me on to the second part
of my talk what is the zuniverse
platform so this universe is the world's
largest platform for online citizen
science
um so to give you a bit of background to
where the zuniverse came from so I'm
sure most of you here would agree that
we're living in an era of unprecedented
data production so although we're moving
to a world in which a large proportion
of this data can be categorized by
computers ever more so a significant
proportion of this data still requires a
human pattern recognition abilities for
analysis so to provide the metadata to
enable Downstream analysis
um however sometimes due to the size of
the data set produced or its complexity
it can be impossible or challenging for
research teams to do this analysis on
their own and this is exactly the
position that this universe co-founder
Chris linto and one of his colleagues
Kelly Kevin
uh found themselves in now over 10 years
ago and they were working to analyze
um hundreds of thousands of images of
galaxies that had been produced by the
Sloan digital Sky survey telescope at
the time although there were computer
processing methods for analyzing data
they weren't adequate for Anna for
providing the metadata that was
necessary to analyze the images being
produced by the telescope and so human
effort remain necessary to categorize
these images
um so after manually categorizing tens
of thousands of these galaxies Kevin and
Chris calculated that even if they
worked 24 hours a day for seven days a
week it would still take them
three to five years approximately to
fully categorize the data set and so
being inspired by sorry being inspired
by similar projects or some citizen
science projects at the time so Stardust
at home was the citizen science project
that had been launched in previous years
they they were inspired by the
beginnings of Citizen science to develop
the first Xenoverse project Galaxy zoo
and this was a project
that simply our sponsors to look at
images of galaxies and to provide some
basic morphological information
and after building and launching this
project it was found that this was a
highly effective means of generating the
data that they needed for their
Downstream analysis and it was
incredibly popular so in the first few
hours after launch
the project received tens of thousands
of classifications per hour and it was
found that because multiple volunteers
examined each and every Galaxy within
the data set that the classifications
were of higher quality than could have
been produced by a single expert looking
at each data point and so the effort
through Galaxy Zoo resulted in the
largest ever Galaxy census and produced
many novel discoveries and many
Publications so it's been a huge
contribution to the scientific
literature
um
interestingly we've we've found through
launching multiples Universe project
that we also observe uh the
identification of many unknown unknowns
within our data sets so something that
we find when working with members of the
public via citizen sciences that people
get distracted so quite often when
looking at through the data volunteers
will go off task and find other things
that are interesting in images and one
such serendipitous Discovery was made by
volunteer honey Von arkel so shortly
after Galaxy zoo was launched uh honey
was inspired to contribute to Galaxy zoo
via one of our other contributors to the
project so
um Brian May of Queen fame
um was was a contributor to Galaxy zoo
and you can see that Honey's got her
guitar in this photo and the image here
and so she noticed in one of the images
she was classifying
um that you can see below the image of
honey there's a green blob just
underneath the Galaxy and it turned out
that this image was uh effectively one
in a million it showed a phenomena that
had previously been theorized but there
hadn't been any evidence to show at that
point and it was an ionized gas cloud
and I'm I'm not an astronomer but
apparently the identification of this
object is something that can be studied
to help us learn more about the early
universe and the evolution of galaxies
so it was a significant unknown unknown
found within the data set and there have
been many other examples like this that
we've found through engaging members of
the public with research
so the effectiveness of engaging the
public in large-scale data analysis has
resulted in many other teams research
teams wishing to adopt a citizen science
approach
and
this has been because many other domains
have experienced a similar increase in
data production capacity so we now have
hundreds of different research projects
on this universe platform looking at all
sorts of phenomena from studying
antibiotic resistance in TB through to
examining penguin population change in
ecology projects we have many Humanities
projects so
involving the transcription of
historical documents
and this is what this universe looks
like as of yesterday so I screen grabbed
these statistics off of the Xenoverse
front page yesterday so as you can see
from this we've had we now have more
than two and a half million registered
volunteers on the platform we have over
350 projects that we've launched on
asuniverse we've had over 700 million
classifications across these projects
and this has resulted in much research
so many papers and many data sets many
analysis and a lot of software that's
been developed as well as part of those
analyzes
um
so how are we applying citizen science
at the Crick
so in a similar origin story to many of
the other research projects that have
utilized the Xenoverse platform at the
citizen science work at the Crick is a
story that starts with too much data so
as I'm sure many of you are aware there
have been a lot of technological
developments within electron microscopy
which mean that it's now possible to
produce terabytes worth of data
overnight
um thousands of images can be produced
exploring the three-dimensional
structure of cells however these
technological developments have pushed
us into a position where the research
bottleneck has now shifted from data
production through to data analysis as
the gold standard approach for analyzing
this data typically remains manual
segmentation by expert electron
microscopics as you can see and one of
my colleagues in this image here doing
segmentation on a desk in the office and
so it's a very slow manual process for
the analyzing this data so the the team
based at the crick in the electron
microscopy science technology platform
had heard of this universe and reached
out to myself and this universe team
back in 2016 with their idea to apply
citizen science for analyzing
um electron micrographs and it was
through this initial conversation that
we decided that we would go ahead and we
would give this a go and build a project
to try and tackle the the segmentation
of electron micrographs and this was the
first time we'd built a project like
this on the Xenoverse there have been
previous projects that had involved the
analysis of micrographs however not the
segmentation so previous projects had
looked at identifying single protein
points within images but would not
previously had volunteers using a
freehand segmentation tool on the
platform so a lot was involved in the
development of this project we had to
develop the drawing tool in order to
enable the task and figure out various
problems like to how to appropriately
display the micrographs while providing
three-dimensional context information
for the volunteers so that they could
perform perform the task
um
in collaboration with the team at the
creek we we identified an appropriate
data set for the analysis we decided to
look at healer cells because they're so
commonly used in biomedical research we
wanted to make sure that the uh the the
the efforts of the contributors the
volunteers would generate
um an analysis that will be as broadly
useful as possible and we decided to
start with the segmentation of the
nuclear envelope because we believed
that it was likely to be one of the most
simple organelles to segment so seemed a
very sensible place to start and it also
mirrored what was quite often the
process of the research teams in
segmenting that they would quite often
start with the the segmentation of this
structure prior to segmenting other
features within the cell
um so we built the project we launched
it after a beta review process and it
RAM for just over a year we collected I
think over a hundred thousand
classifications from volunteers over our
data set
and after looking at the state data we
were very pleased to find that despite
it being a challenging task and despite
there not being a precedent of other
projects taking this approach on the
platform the volunteers were very good
at doing segmentation so if you click on
these on the left hand image you'll see
all of the segmentations submitted by
volunteers for a single image within our
data set that was uploaded to the
project and you'll see that although
there's variability most of the
segmentations are very good
and the image on the left hand side that
you can see also speaks to this that as
you would expect from volunteer
classifications
um you can see that there is variability
that some people do segment other pixels
that are quite far from the future of
Interest however you can see from this
image that
when it comes to a consensus when you
look at all of the segmentations
together
uh what what we want the segmentation of
the nuclear envelope emerges from the
multiple classifications and this brings
me to the next Slide the points of
aggregation so one of the biggest
challenges that we encountered with this
project was how to make sense of the
multiple segmentations per image so we
had to work quite carefully to figure
out a way to form consensus a single
segmentation from the multiple
segmentations that were submitted by
volunteers for each slice of our data
set and we developed a new aggregation
algorithm that we called Korea and the
the headline finding from the slide is
that it worked well we were able to form
an appropriate analysis pipeline that
could take the volunteer segmentations
and produce something that worked really
nicely
so clicking through to the next slide I
think this is an embedded field
be able to play for you here so you
should be seeing so these were the 18
nuclei within our volume
um
segmented so all of these represent just
pure volunteer efforts and as you can
see in very high quality we had some
expert data some expert regions of
interest and we found that the volunteer
data compared very well to the expert
segmentations that we had
however even with volunteer help we
found well we're aware that the amount
of data being produced by the microscopy
community means that we need other
approaches we need to adopt machine
learning algorithms into our pipelines
um so we used the data that the
volunteers produce the aggregated
segmentations and we trained a
convolutional neural network to perform
the automatic segmentation of the
nuclear envelope and this performed very
well so I'll just toggle on to the next
slide and
um
video for you so this shows in gold is
the expert data green as the volunteer
data in magenta is the the convolutional
neural network predicted segmentation
for them for the uh nuclei for this
particular cell and you can see that
they're all highly comparable
and
moving on to the next video this is just
showing uh moving up through the volume
so that you can see the two-dimensional
segmentations for each individual slice
them again you can see that the the
three the the volunteer aggregations and
the Machine prediction were very
comparable to the expert data so to
conclude it worked well
um and
say sorry just waiting for this video to
buffer so the the critical part of this
research so that the real kind of
headline finding of this project was
that we were able to
drastically reduce the amount of time
taken to segment the nuclei within the
data set and uh we found so
it apparently would take a single expert
approximately 30 hours of effort to
segment a single nuclei however
are our predictive algorithm took only
one minute so with this approach we were
able to uh
increase data analysis by a factor of
about 1800 so the data analysis of our
um from our predictive algorithm to
segment one nuclei was 1800 times faster
than than an expert and we ran our model
on other data sets as well and we found
that this model also performed well in
novel Concepts so on
data of higher resolution data produced
by different modalities say fibsum and
we also found surprisingly that our
model was able to perform well on a
mitotic cell and even though the nuclear
envelope in this case as you can see
from this image the the nuclear envelope
is slightly degraded our model was still
able to identify the nuclear envelope in
this context
um so the success of this project meant
that we have taken this approach forward
and we're developing other projects and
these these are a handful of the
projects that we've had on the Xenoverse
platform a number of these are now
completes from were in the process of
analyzing the data from these projects
with run projects to look at
mitochondria the endoplasmic reticulum
and fat droplets and these have been
brought together under what's called an
organization so it's just multiple
similar projects on this universe
platform and I should say as well
um that we've got some new projects in
the work and works and we're looking to
share these
um to our volunteer community for review
very shortly so this this is a um slight
Advance on what we've been doing
previously we'll be using
um correlative light images in
conjunction with the EM images to guide
foreign volunteer segmentation in these
in this context because
uh we're we're now moving into
structures that require markers to be
unambiguously identified so things like
the lysosomes and the Golgi of the cell
which very difficult to identify just
from the electron micrographs Alone
um so it's exciting times in PH reverse
so this just brings me on to the final
part of the talk I appreciate that I'm
close to the half hour now so I'll go
through this very quickly so if this has
inspired any of you to build your own
Universe projects
um it's straightforward so a few years
ago this universe built a project
Builder interface that's free to use to
generate your own citizen science
project and it's available available at
this URL
um accessible on the xenos platform
um there are three core components I
would say to think about when you're
building your projects
um you will need to think about the data
that you want to share so
um and I should say that this universe
is able to share share multiple types of
data with volunteers so we can share
images we can share video we can share
audio and we're also moving to a state
of being able to show data to the
volunteers in the form of interactable
graphs
um you will also need to think about the
tasks so the series of uh tasks that you
will be asking the volunteers to do to
generate the metadata that you require
for
for your Downstream analysis and we're
able to handle questions drawings texts
and surveys
and you'll also need to think about the
community that you'd like to engage with
via your project and it's possible to
share as Universe projects with uh
members of the public open beyond this
universe platform
all privately with your own communities
so to get started with building yours
Universe projects you'll need to First
register that's the only prerequisite to
build a project sign in and click build
a project so it's it's as simple as
hitting that tab
creating new projects and then filling
in some very basic information
um
this is all editable Downstream so you
can you can change for this before you
launch your project
um and their just to draw your your
attention to two of the most important
tabs on the project Builder the
workflows and the subject sets so all of
these different fields on the left hand
side of the project Builder page refer
to
various important components of building
a project
um however I'd say these two are likely
the most important so subject sets is
where you upload your data there's a
graphical user interface where you can
just drag and drop
and there's also a python client for
more complexity drop loads as well I
should say
for workflows the workflow tab is
corresponds to the sequence of tasks
that you would like the volunteers to
perform and as I've said there are
multiple task types
from asking questions such as which
segmentation best highlights the
boundary in the case of synaptic
proteins you there are survey tasks
these are commonly used in ecology
projects to populate with multiple
options alongside images to help guide
Volunteers in in the task there's also
transcription and this is commonly used
in Humanities style projects to
transcribe texts from pages
others also drawing tasks which you'll
be familiar with from from this
presentation the freehand drawing task
and also there's the possibility of
putting single points on images to
identify things like the position of
white blood cells in the case of monkey
Health Explorer
um and yes the segmentation of
biological structures in hsl
and then uh if if you want to share your
project with the private Community you
can go to town as much as you like with
with the various other features of the
project or more or less dependent on on
your own needs however if you wish to
share your project with the Xenoverse
Community
then the other fields will need to be
completed to a good standard the project
will be reviewed by members of this
universe team and also the Xenoverse
Community before being approved for
launch if the project reaches the
appropriate standard
um and as I say you can share your
project with your own private
communities or the public
um there there can be different benefits
to either approach that I won't go into
depth about here
um there are many other further
resources out there
and if you are interested and you'd like
to connect and learn more I'm very happy
to
receive emails and connect
um so do get in touch and thank you for
listening
thank you Dr Spears for your insightful
presentation it's very impressive how
much you've been able to achieve by
involving citizen science volunteers
we'll now start taking live
um questions for the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask Dr
Spears please do so now by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left side of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so I have my first question here for you
let's see
you touched upon this briefly how do you
get around integrator variability and
signal to noise detection in your
current study
what are some good measures that people
can think about as they design their own
studies
um
sorry can you repeat the question
variability yes
um so
I think
some of the first things to think about
when designing your study you'll want to
make sure that you're starting from a
sensible point in terms of the quality
of your data so making sure that the
data is as clear as possible so that the
features of interest that you want to be
annotated are as clear as possible and
also so I didn't touch on this at all
but there are other mechanisms of making
those features of Interest clearer so
for example in the ER project we we used
a label to make the endoplasmic
reticulum clearer relative to the
background and
similarly with with the correlative data
that we're using within the projects to
look at the lysosomes and golges that's
sort of a similar approach so I think as
a very
uh sensible First Step just making sure
that the data that you've got is as
clear as possible and that the features
that you're interested in are
highlighted as clearly as possible is a
very good place to start and then
ensuring that the the instructions that
you give are as clear as possible
providing good examples so that's all
very good practice within project
building making sure that you provide
good tutorials good field guides good
instructions for the volunteers so
things are as clear as possible and also
there's a lot of nuance when it comes to
selecting the appropriate fields of view
to make sure that you're focusing
people's attention onto what's
interesting so in taking the um nuclear
envelope project for example we had as
you live gathered from the data that I
showed we had a very large volume that
we were interested in but there were
multiple cells within that volume so we
made decisions to focus on uh the 18
nuclei that was selected as regions of
interest in the uh cropped those out
that made the subjects for each of those
regions of Interest so that we could
focus attention onto onto smaller areas
so that there was less confusion
um between the different nuclei or less
possibility for confusion so I think
there's a lot to be said about good
project design and simplicity but then
also you do you have to
have mechanisms in mind for the
aggregation pathway down the line so
um as as I discussed we we had to
develop a novel aggregation algorithm
for the nuclear envelope and that was
partly because the freehand tool had
never been used on this universe before
so it was a lot of work
generating that tool so that we could we
could reduce the noise between the
volunteers and
remove outlying data sensibly
awesome thank you very much
I have a next question here what are
some of the techniques to motivate
citizen science volunteers to
participate
um so I think in citizen science broadly
there are
lots of different ways you can motivate
people one of the conversations that we
have on sort of a six monthly basis or
so within those Universe team is the
idea of gamification
um but it's it's a cop we tend to are
away from this universe side because we
find that people's intrinsic motivations
contribute to research uh from you know
wanting to help science or just pure
interest in subject matter seems to be
motivation enough for people to
contribute so we find that sometimes
when you gamify because some projects in
the past have explored it sensitively in
the minor way and it's been found that
it's led to unexpected consequences in
terms of data quality so I think uh we
we tend to just rely on people's
motivation
uh but there are other things that you
can do and there are other things that
other teams do
fantastic well thank you very much for
the uh for your very thoughtful um
answers to the questions
thank you again Dr Spears for your time
today and your important research
now we'll move on to our second speaker
oh sure
Dr Martin prisoner Dr prisner you may
now begin your presentation
thank you very much for having me and
for giving me the opportunity to present
the research that I uh okay I need to I
hope that you can see my slides now yeah
thank you very much for having me and
for giving me the opportunity to present
to you the research that I've carried
out during the time of my PhD which I've
carried out at Imperial College London
where I developed a tool which we call
Coffee which stands for Content aware
frame interpolation and in
during the talk I will go through four
parts of my presentation where in the
first part I will explain a little bit
more about the full type of our
publication actually means then I will
give you
um introduction into the complications
of fluorescence microscopy and how
coffee could be helpful for you to
overcome some of those limitations then
uh in part three I will share some of
our own experimental results which we
have
um conducted and carried out using this
tool and in part of uh part four I will
show you a brief demonstration of how
you could use this tool for your own
research
um
okay
to the title so content aware frame
interpolation this basically means um
content aware that we use data to use a
tool which learns from
which learns uh to to learn patterns
from data to to basically perform the
task of frame interpretation which means
if we have a sequence of microscopy
images
um that we increase the frame rate of
those images given for example three
input frames that the model learns to
um the patterns of those movements from
one frame to the next interpolate an
intermediate frame between two
consecutive images so resulting out of
three input frames giving five output
frames then deep learning based super
resolution I know we're going a little
bit into the like foundations but
considering that they it could be that
there are a lot of people which have
different backgrounds I still explain it
and deep learning is basically a a sub
part of artificial intelligence and also
a subcategory of machine learning and to
achieve basically the aim that we
increase the temporal resolution we use
the neural networks to basically achieve
this task and finally we apply this tool
which we
implemented on different bioimaging
platforms meaning on different microsc
microscopy modalities
so basically why can coffee be helpful
for microscopists so especially when you
do fluorescence microscopy with probably
um focal micro microscopes they often
have the problem which is called the
Eternal triangle of compromise which
means that at the given resolution and
then and speed and sensitivity that you
can just optimize or improve one
parameter of those parameters by
compromising one or the other so for
example if you want to improve the
resolution of your collected image this
means that the speed of collection will
be reduced or for example if you want to
increase the speed of collecting the
images then the shutter which allows the
photons of the fluorescence to which the
detector will be open for a shorter
period of time which then reduces the
sensitivity and therefore the signal to
noise ratio another challenge
which is often a problem for
microscopists is that um it's called
photo toxicity which means that
basically cells which are exposed to
laser light
um for a longer period of time the the
cells will become unhappy and eventually
die which means that also the the
scientists carrying out those
experiments will be unhappy as well
because you cannot observe the
biological processes that they are
interested in
another problem is also photo bleaching
which means that the fluorescent probe
which is taken up by the cell
um and and which basically causes the
fluorescence emit emission after
excitation of the laser light gets
weaker over time so the longer you
measure a cell given an exposure to to
the laser the weaker the signal becomes
and the less you can see actually the
the labored compound of Interest
and all those limitations become even
more pronounced and more limiting
um when you look into multi-color
Imaging or three or 40 Imaging processes
which take longer period of time and
therefore
um make those problems even more
pronounced
um
some ways of overcoming this these
challenges could be that to basically
get better Hardware but this obviously
that the costs and sometimes it's
intrinsically not not possible because
of intrinsic limitations of the hardware
another solution would be to use better
floral Force but this comes with the
same limitations that they are just
sometimes not available
[Applause]
[Music]
carried out prior and which one of them
was carried out by one valve when while
he was working at Google who implemented
the depth where frame interpolation tool
and Xiao you Chang implemented the
zooming slo-mo Network which both of
them are capable of interpolating images
along the time axis in this case of
video frames
of which the assuming slow-mo network is
also capable of upscaling the image and
improving the image resolution so what
we did in our research for the
implementation of coffee is that we
basically implemented to networks of
which we took the depth of where premium
interpolation as it is and we changed
the the structure of the students
Network that it can be performed the
interpolation step without any upscaling
capabilities but we also kept the this
option as well in case if people are
interesting to interested in exploring
this functionality as well
okay so what are the actual capabilities
of coffee so the the basic one is as I
described before that you have a
microscopy sequence maybe some cells
moving over time and
um basically by applying coffee on your
data set which you have you can improve
the image density of the of the image
sequence which you collected and by
iteratively applying the same
um algorithm or the same tool on
iterative iterative iteratively on the
same data set allows you to even further
improve the density of the the image
sequence
this is one option another option which
we also explored
um was to basically use the same tool
along the set dimension of the data so
if you have set Stacks where you recall
a sales
um in different depth Dimensions you can
use the same tool to improve the
density of information in this Dimension
as well or you can even combine both of
the functionalities to basically perform
interpolation step along the T Dimension
and the sets Dimension improving the
amount of information generated by by
the AI basically obviously the the last
step is very challenging one because it
assumes that the interpolation steps
which have been carried out by the time
um Dimension is accurate and if there
are some artifacts which are created in
the um it's like more pronounced in the
second iteration step so this needs to
be taken with caution when applying
buying this kind of methodology to your
data
and so how did we evaluate actually
kafi's performance on our own data sets
so the basic methodology was that we
have a sequence a sequence of of some
microscopy images where we basically
have a ground truth sequence where we
remove every second image and then in a
an interpolation step we interpolate the
missing frames back into the sequence
and then compare basically the the
ground truth sequence with the coffee
interpolated sequence and in order to
find out how well it performed we
evaluated the resulting output with
three different evaluation metrics one
being the root mean square error and the
peak signal into the noise ratio which
are both pixel based evaluation metrics
and we also evaluated it on the
structural similarity Matrix which is a
more structural based similarity metrics
commonly used in computer vision
tasks and we compared basically the
output of the coffee networks with three
and traditional ways of Performing um
temporal interpolation which is by cubic
and bilinear interpolation and non-news
basically just a simple frame
duplication to see how much the the
network actually improves over a single
comparison of the input side
and now I'll show you
um
now I'll show you an example which we
where we applied basically this
methodology on one data set this is my
200 data set we're in the left upper
corner you see the input on the right
upper corner you see the ground truth
um of the of the data set and in the
middle you see the coffee intercalated
sequence and we performed it basically
with one time temporal
um
um up stealing and in the second time we
performed the upscaling twice you can
see that the overall movement looks much
smoother in comparison to the input
sequence because it contains much more
frames obviously
um but on the other hand you can also
see that the and I will restart the
video just to show you this again
but you can also see that the randomness
of the movement from the ground truth
gets lost in this process because there
is something which is intrinsically not
possible for the network to pick up in
this in this example
and in the lower parts you see actually
the comparisons between the ground rules
and the input and ground rules to the
coffee Integrity with outputs
okay
now looking at the numbers of the
similarity metrics which I described to
you before you can see that basically
the traditional interpolation techniques
um are performing worse in comparison to
the
um coffee networks so and already the
pre-trained network which has not been
fine-tuned on any of the data is already
outperforming the the traditional
mathematical approaches and when after
fine-tuning the networks you can see
that the
um the performance even increases uh
even further
the next next we actually tried to use a
more systematic approach to evaluate
this network and this was by basically
um choosing a simulated data sets and
where we could control each parameter
like the size of the of the dots the
speed the input which the the dots were
moving around the random Direction
changes and a lot of other parameters
and we applied basically the same
methodology to to this kind of
experimental setup
again here you can see again this upper
corner is the input for the input frames
right upper corner is the the ground
truth and in the center you can see the
in this case the Dyne interculated
um images and now with four times
upscaling along the time Dimension you
can see that the
also the randomness of the movement gets
lost but the overall direction of the
frames are reproduced actually quite
nicely
and again looking at the evaluation
metrics so in this case we actually
performed the experiment also
um checking how well the network
performs different movement speeds of
those
um of those dots and so we can see that
in both cases like for slow and fast
movements both and networks within our
coffee framework perform better than the
traditional approaches but we can see
that with increasing particle speeds
the performance also drops
um which is understandable because the
quicker the particles move the more
difficult it is actually also for them
to pick up the direction and the
overall speed of the particles and if
you look in some on some of the errors
in the lower part of the image you can
see a higher velocity and higher
particle speeds the networks start
making mistakes which is something that
that everybody who is using such tools
needs to be aware of for example Dane
um is basically when it's not sure in
which which direction the particle is
moving because of the very high speed
then it starts interpolating the images
into two different directions where both
of them could be a possible Solution on
the other hand assuming slo-mo actually
um doesn't interpolate the the points
which it doesn't know where to put them
and so those are basically artifacts
which need to be considered when you do
Downstream analysis in a later stage ah
okay I just realized I forgot to push
the slides but I hope now you can see it
so basically
um the
left panel shows again the performance
of the networks in comparison to the
traditional methods where the coffee
networks perform better than the
traditional ones and
website in the pictures you can see some
of the artifacts which are created when
moving to going to very high velocities
next we actually tried to evaluate the
network also on its ability to improve
the tracking results of those particles
so using this simulate the data sets
gave us the possibility to basically use
um the ground truth ground truth facts
of those particles and compare it then
in the end with the particles of the
interpolated Networks
together
um as mentioned before you can see that
the ground truth
um particle movements are actually a
little bit more random which means that
they have like some brownie motion which
uh the the dean and the CSS Network
cannot like um correctly reproduce but
the overall Trends are fairly similar
and
when looking at the results we basically
applied the 2014 is BD particle tracking
challenge metrics on to the performance
which we are onto the analysis which we
carried out on the simulated data set we
can see that again like I said s d in
perform better than non and bilinear
interpolation and interestingly bilinear
performed worse in comparison to to a
simple frame duplication because
bilinear interpolation basically
linearly Blends together two consecutive
frames producing a lot of artifacts
which obviously the tracking algorithm
has troubles with coping with it and
um we also performed the same experiment
then on ground on real lysosomal data
where we had the problem that we didn't
really have the ground truth tracks but
for
um like simply simplifying this problem
we basically took the ground truth
tracks from the ground truth sequence
and compared basically the interculated
results with the ground truth
um tracking results as a comparison
and also in this case we can see that
the specifically is the assuming slow-mo
performed better than uh Dane and then
both of them perform better than the
more classical interpolation results
um now we can also look into one example
zoomed in section where you can see for
example where some of the lysosomes
which are moving around will be missed
from the basically the non-interpret
related images
okay
and now actually
um yeah because of interest of time I
probably just show you one more example
of
of a data set which where we also apply
coffee to this was a quite challenging
one because there's a lot of movement
happening
um within just in
going new this again because it's quite
quick and short
but then the left lower corner you see
the input image and in the right side
you see the two interpolation results of
coffee
and
now I just briefly show you
um like a demonstration a pre-recorded
demonstration of how you close this tool
to for your own project basically by
using a Google collab notebook
or basically the tool is implemented in
Google collab which is a open source or
like openly available Source on Google
and it's divided in different sections
where you find a lot of information of
how to use the notebook and how to
basically operate it and first you need
to connect it to the Cloud Server
because it will use basically a GPU
which is provided by Google after
running this cell you will see whether
you have a GPU available or not then if
you don't have it you can go to those
settings and select the GPU in case if
it isn't connected then you connect it
to your Google Cloud Storage in this
case Google Drive so after copying the
registration key there will be a folder
showing up on the left hand side where
you have access to all the data which is
available on Google Drive and this is to
upload also for your for your images
then by running the this cell in section
2 you install all the necessary packages
which are necessary for running this
this notebook there you find also there
will be a new folder appearing calling
Zoom interpolation where you have a demo
folder with some examples then for doing
your own training you can
um select your own training data which
will be processed by The Notebook it's
recommended that for bigger data sets
which are bigger than 10 GB it's
recommended to use the scripts provided
and do it offline because Google collab
has also some limitations in the compute
performance but for smaller data sets
it's absolutely possible to run it
within the notebook and so you can just
select the
um the data you want to process and uh
at that that's the by right clicking you
can select the path and then you select
also the the image size and then after
running the cell there will be two new
folders appearing which you can then
select for actually running the training
and for the training you again need to
select those two preparation folders
which have been occurred in the previous
step and you need to select also whether
you want to have any assuming
capabilities or and also the input
dimensions of the
images need to be provided and also how
many iterations you want to train the
network for how often should the
checkpoints be saved because there's the
option to save also the intermediate
results of the of the network and the
learning rate needs to be selected and
so on
and the warmer Pizza basically tells you
how many iteration it takes for the
learning rate to reach its full height
basically
and after after you have specified the
parameters you can just run the cell and
it will load basically the data which
you've processed before and runs the
fine tuning
after this has finished you can also
visualize those results
um to see whether how well the model has
you then also upload the new model to
the
um to the to the software
so the tool basically that it knows that
it will use the free Trend model
and then it's basically that you show
basically just uh the the learning
effect of the of the fine tuning in this
case it's trust Administration
and then you can move on to section five
where you can actually perform the
interpolation on your own data so you
select again from your Google drive
folder the folder where the the images
are located you select the image
dimension of with how big the images you
select in which dimension you want to
interpolate this image and key or sets
dimension and then you're basically
ready to go and after then you also
select the location where the output
should be stored
or saved it's very recommendable to
choose a folder inside your Google drive
because if the
um the notebook disconnects and data
would be lost but then usually this is a
standard setup and after running the
server it basically will use the folder
that you provided with the data and
creates your new folder with the
interpolated images
um which you can can download basically
to for your own inspection
so by just right clicking it's like in
the Explorer you can just right click
and press download and then it will
download the file onto your computer or
otherwise if it's stored on your Google
Drive you can just download it with the
on your Google Drive via the browser in
the last section there are some more
details on how you can evaluate the
images which I won't go into more
details because of the interest of time
but um if you're interested in how to
use it there's a more detailed
explanation video online on my GitHub
repository and if you're interested I
highly recommend you can watch that and
go through the whole methodology slower
step-by-step and for in in general I
would recommend people who are
interested in using it to first use it
with our provided pre-trained networks
our pre-trained models then you see
whether the results are actually already
looking promising if they do so then you
can go ahead and fine-tune the network
and the find tuning step is actually
something which is sometimes a little
bit like tricky to do because you need
to set the parameters right the learning
rate and so on so it will take some time
to get it correct
um that's why I would recommend using it
in the first place
um with our pre-train networks to not
waste your time basically and now I
almost reach the end of my presentation
where I want to point you out to the
direction of where you can find this
tool so it's basically hosted by the
zero cross deep learning for microscopy
platform which has a lot of other very
interesting tools deep learning tools
for microscopy which you can use
starting from nuclear segmentation
denoising image up feeling artificial
labeling and they all follow basically
the same pipeline of data processing you
can optimize on Google Drive you can
process and fine-tune the network using
the Google collab environment and you
can perform the inference producing a
new output and then you analyze it on
your own computer and there are a lot of
helpful tutorials which you can also
watch which will help you to basically
get along and with this I reached the
end of my presentation I am the final
word of caution is that everybody knows
that deep learning and AI can produce
magical really nice results but it's
always important to whenever you use
those tools that you evaluate the models
on your output and check whether the
results are actually
um what you expect them to do and so on
so always use those tools to us with
caution now I reached the end of the
presentation where I want to thank all
the collaborators which helped me to to
perform this kind of research with a
special highlights to Romaine Lane which
stepped in as an additional supervisor
since my background is actually more
from the chemistry side and I want to
thank also my supervisors which allowed
me to explore this area of research
during my PhD and also the funding
bodies basically paying for for all my
fund research that I was allowed to do
and yeah thank you for your attention
thank you Dr prisoner for your
insightful presentation
we'll now start the Q a portion of the
webinar for either speaker in fact if
you missed your opportunity to ask Dr
Spears if you have a question to ask
please do so now by clicking on ask the
question box located on the far left
side of your screen
so we have a first question for you Dr
prusner
with the explosion of the number of
available deep learning algorithms such
as Cafe what do you think an average
biologist can do to get started with AI
and deep learning
um that's a very good question I think
I think nowadays we already reached a
point that not uh so much coding skills
are actually necessary to really use
deep learning algorithms there are a lot
of tools out there which make it very
easy for microscopics and biologists
which are not fluent for example in
python or in other any other programming
language to actually just go online and
use those tools one platform which I've
highlighted is basically this zero cost
for the L
um for microscopy platform which is
basically a no code solution for for
this kind of task so you can actually
without any coding skills use those kind
of tools
um from your browser and it makes it
quite easy and there are a lot of other
tools available out there already
integrated in feature or in icy in some
other Imaging processing platforms and
um I think in the future this will be
even more
um more more common to be integrated in
in normal in image analysis pipelines
and so yeah I think just watch out for
those Solutions which are out there and
don't be afraid to step in and try to
use them even though it sounds like you
need to know coding but it's sometimes
easier than you think yeah
thank you very much the next question is
um in deep learning what are some
measures that can be implemented to
avoid or minimize artifacts
um this I guess is a question which
everybody would like to know in very
detail that it's a very difficult
question to to really answer in in great
Precision because it always depends on
on the tasks that you're looking at so
with image processing obviously you have
nowadays quite easy ways of collecting a
lot of images so and usually what's in
the field of computer vision or in your
field of deep learning is that the more
data you have the better the results are
and so but even if like because you can
train the network on bigger data sets
and then it learns to generalize the
better to the data that it's trained on
um
other ways of like overcoming this
challenge might be if you have like
limited data available for your for your
training that you can use some data
augmentation
um methods where you basically flip and
rotate and drop images to basically
augment your data set which increases
the amount of data that you have
available for training
um but finally it always comes down to
the person carrying out the research to
to basically see whether the results
from the network are reflected correctly
in what you expect to see and so it's
always important to perform some
Downstream analysis on the data that you
are applying the network on to make sure
that no artifacts get created what are
the artifacts that are created are not
um influencing your your research
thank you very much I know we've gone
over time a little bit there's one other
question that I'd like your thoughts on
some researchers are skeptical about
reproducibility about AI assisted or
generated results especially when it
comes to predictive models
what can users to improve
reproducibility when it comes to deep
learning models such as Cafe
yeah so reproducibility is a common
issue for deep learning as well because
deep learning is seen as this kind of
black box which does something and
nobody really knows what's happening
underneath but um in the end what is
important is that whoever uses coffee or
any other deep learning tool is that
they provide the pre-trained models for
other people to
um to reproduce to be able to reproduce
what they have observed and another
thing what people need to pay attention
to is that also those treatment models
can have some
um have some problems intrinsically in
the training that for example if some
training or some testing data gets
um into the training it would basically
teach the neural network to memorize
patterns from the results that it's
actually about to predict and then it's
artificially increasing the performance
which is actually not the case so it's
important to then also provide the
training data to the users that they can
actually really reproduce the training
it themselves as well to to make sure
that this is not artificially
um improved by by maybe some mishandling
of the data sets
fantastic youngster thank you so much uh
thank you again to both of you Dr
prisoner and Dr Spears for your time
today and your important research
that concludes our presentation on
behalf of Leica Microsystems we'd like
to thank lab roots for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to again thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provide at the
time of registration
the webcasts can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may be interested in this
topic of AI microscopy until next time
take care everyone thank you so much and
goodbye
thank you